places so here we're in the sand Kingdom
in the town of toasted Rana and there
they have problem now because it's all
frozen everything is cold for reasons of
course that Mario will eventually solve
you actually be Hank tell soaking second
we can show his alive ennovation oh yeah
yeah yeah oh he's cold
I love the locals here too yeah I think
he's distracted by the by the local
dancing around but I think if he's by
himself and he really shivers Oh Mariana
so let's see here what's the one thing I
did want to show off is so as I
mentioned there's two kinds of coins in
this game and for the I believe the
first time in the main main line Mario
series you can actually five things with
your coins and I wanted to ask the
developers how that came up you know
that currency should be worth currency
monday coin did came on the Qt runs type
Pokemon - Wow
hi I'm gonna put you all alternate
alternate estates go to register so we
wanted you know coins to be used as
coins in this game actually use them as
money Oh
Geico pony totally nice hello can you
know can it this boy you know guy you
sure you know what device and you know I
think I think you'll agree you know if
you go to your foreign land one of the
things that makes the biggest impression
on you is the currency equal its carried
over what that is you know you kind of
look at anything
wait is this this is real can I use this
local guy Ilario my you don't like when
your additional this oh no Kuni soul
okay no Quentin Morris Dees and since
you know Mario is going around to all
these different kingdoms in this case
we wanted to make sure that there was a
currency Freeport he also Podesta sort
of point O Salafi muscle their ultimatum
on a post terminal Katya know me already
and you know they're a collectible items
so you can use them to buy different
outfits or buy souvenirs yeah yeah and
it's always fun to buy souvenirs right
yeah absolutely
speaking of shopping we are now in crazy
cap so there's two there's two kinds of
coins as we mentioned the the purple
ones are unique to the the local Kingdom
the yellow ones are going to used in any
shop I'm going to buy because the the
guy at the door said maybe I should I'm
not living up for their dress code maybe
I should buy some clothes to fit in
better I'm going to buy a local sombrero
and poncho and wait to see how adorable
Mario looks being adorable I just love
the shopkeeper yeah and their huge stack
of hats is so cute and you can see some
of the souvenirs you can buy there that
you can use to decorate the inside of
the ship nice and now I am rocking this
look let's go try that door again
so my capabilities are the same you know
I still have it's still Cappy even
though he's turned into a different kind
of hat now he can turn into any kind of
headwear apparently the exotic
superpower and alright so I go over and
talk to this guy see if you meet the
expectations down
snappy and lively snappy and lively I
think what the Hat is the one of the
Poncho's the other
and this is of course what the goal that
was working toward all this time I love
all these little moments of surprise
where you never really know what's gonna
happen don't you you I don't want to get
an aces I don't know why where to go to
this room so I could play a guitar
I'll get it because it's a lot yeah
exactly so then we're going to move on
to some more traditional 3d Mario game
play over this direction now that you
are terribly well dressed it's time to
go do some exploring yeah say what
principals be on the right track so
notice that by using the motion controls
I can actually use the little homing
function on the Hat more easily it is
possible with the button controls only
but it's much more difficult right the
classic Goomba yeah and let's just do a
big one for
for that
and that's I guess I think books are
probably noticing here so you're not
capturing those goombah it's not every
single enemy that's capturable that's
true you've got to find the special ones
yeah and a lot of its having a good eye
and just experimenting a lot with this
cap I think they're a shape bigger the
ones who can capture
[Music]
some bullet bills of course are useful
because you can fly with them
and now I've got to very quickly capture
my ride back
I'm with little bills they you can only
capture them for a limited amount of
time because at some point they're just
gonna blow up so you have to be a little
mindful of what you're doing yeah you
only could have much time with the
explosive guys and then almost to one of
my favorite bits in this level
oh yeah the next figure coming up to you
yeah blew my mind the first time I saw
it so this place has these murals that
look like they're decorated in this cool
Oh old-school aesthetic and I'm just
going to go right on in and I just look
at my costume so I'm quite sure this on
a mote of Khorasan I think we definitely
need to hear a little bit more
background about why you added this into
the game because it's so cool but it's
so unexpected as well I think Monday
only gonna - do you know how to become a
little more macho cool on Saturday keone
she cooks Takeo Rebecca things so I
wanted to make something that would be
sort of a contrast with the 3d stages
that you're able to explore very freely
so Dean of the law school she almost had
King tapenade ooh
Jose you know you know the 2d the 2d
spaces are kind of more confined they're
more precise you know it's more like
kind of sort of traditional platforming
elements oh jeez you know the most like
that she got a solution
and but also within the 2d stages as you
can see we wanted to have a lot of
different variety what you know Lucas
got a lot let's get x10 mode on the
simulator and of course you know with
the visuals we're hoping it's something
other people who enjoyed kind of those
classic manic games also get a kick out
of as well so one thing I'd love to show
off when we're getting out toward the
end of this space is just how much the
music changes when we're transitioning
back and forth you know we've been
chatting maybe it's hard for some folks
to hear what's been going on here but if
we just pop in and out of that warp pipe
it's a pretty impressive transition when
the music ages
but there's no warpath about here
yeah but you can now see that's more of
a naturalistic instruments so I'm going
to skip ahead and show off of the last
part of this this scenario okay so that
not only these wrist straps people
always restaurants yes house it's
jumping okay it's worth mentioning too
that we're only covering a tiny bit of
what is in this kingdom there's so much
there do and explore there's just a
ridiculous or not alright so here we are
this is much later in the level I'm
still got my snappy outfit though and
watch these bullet bills transition out
of the 2d and then I'm going to use one
to break open this wall so other words
really handled out the bullet bills as a
captured target you'll see here when
you're trying to target for really
precision flying it's got a little bit
no I'm doing that's but it's got a
little bit of a headlamp so you can kind
of use to line yourself up it's super
handy that's okay because we get to see
this cute 2d to 3d transition yellow
girls it's so cool
all right you guys all right here we go
and with the bullet bills you can also
give yourself a little speed bursts as
well shaking the droidcon will let you
go a little bit further so it's worth
experimenting once you get a feel for
the timing of how long it will last
it's kind of like driving a car it
doesn't have any brake pedal if you can
go faster you can steer but that's all
you've been here and alright so up here
we're going to confront one of the
brutal 's and folks we've seen them in
our original teaser trailer for this
game they are an evil wedding planning
firm and I'd love to hear more from the
developers about how they came to be and
what your favorite brutal is right that
is G sounds like that's gonna take long
suckers get a group photo she's ghetto
Hey H we each one key you know try to
decide so there are no corrida ah ah no
cook funny yeah to edit a coupon okay Co
Co Co Co Co to Steve so they you know as
you kind of said they've they've been
employed by Bowser they're in charge of
making sure his wedding goes off by the
hitch the kick goes shigoto chitosan and
they're very serious about the work that
their work ethic is admirable
[Music]
my mother needed
topless a like beef ownage on abortion
cupboard Palin I cannot relate in this
baby more sorry Dan inaudible personal
top 5 favorite burger
how do and you know my favorite is a
topper the kind of shorter one who has
that green top yeah I agree
yeah yeah topper know what you have
cause you're assembling the favorite so
doesn't it your time totally my visit
Harriet fun do you call you sang is a
thorough get up that others good now go
go I got it
squiggle me people Chauhan on there on
all wanted a solution
what's your handle this is really good
timing because the character I like the
most is the one you're fighting right
now Harriet she has this great contrast
between her cute appearance and my how
devilish she is she's sort of like the
tricky little sister of the group here
our attacks are really fun to watch as
well especially when she starts flying
around and it's worth mentioning you
fight each of the brutal a few times but
they're their tactics get more and more
intense and dangerous I'll be honest
having planned a wedding last year I
would take the help of people wedding
planner yeah I mean any evil help is
better than no help and they're very
dedicated to their work and they're
willing to fight your enemies for you
and that's pretty brave oh nice
there we go nicely done
thank you oh now she'll be back
all right so that's a grand moon worth
three power moons and there we see Cathy
in his natural state as well
there is celebrating Macario
[Music]
all right so that's what we have for
gameplay for right now but we did have
one more little feature I believe yeah